si on prend les froids yable n'est pas
une petite barre là moi j'ai une grosse
bague est prise en compte par les trolls
les travaillistes eux-mêmes et
eh bien
alors à venir se propose de nous pencher
sur la chute des cheveux avec le dr
david elia et qui est nôtre gynécologue
selvi je suis effectivement à partisans
de lapine de la peine demain et je suis
partisan de l'application de la peine de
mort ap le volontarisme républicain si
vous préférez je veux mettre au service
des injustices plus de moyens mais qui
peut me le reprocher le sexe ce qu'il ya
de plus profond dans l'homme dans la
femme un kilt en france est la coupe de
france l'accord d'exploration et
d'exploitation de gisements de gaz de
shit de schiste compte tenu des compte
tenu des méthodes les infirmières qui
est qui bourré qui mouraient beaucoup
dans les hôpitaux m
incroyable